how to raise your price without pissing
anyone off the way to make any change
whether it's price or programmatic is
actually to appeal to a higher ideal you
will always have the high ground in any
discussion if you go off morality and so
what that means is if i say hey i made
you this promise that i wanted to
fulfill i want to help you achieve this
thing i have the moral duty to help you
do that i no longer feel like the
services that we have can help it now
that i know what i know now because i am
a growing entrepreneur and i've learned
more things these are the things that i
have to do in order to fill my original
promise and part of that means it's
going to cost more and that's okay
because for me my integrity is number
one and that is what i'm going to
maintain so as a result of this change
in price these are all the additional
things you're going to get it's going to
happen faster it's going to happen
easier for you and all of these because
i have to stay true to my promise and
that's what i'm going to do and so when
you make it that way no one can question
you because they're like why don't you
raise your pressure you're asking me to
question my integrity you have the high
ground no one can counter you there and
that's how you make those kind of big
problematic changes that you're afraid
of making